Mr. Secretary-General, Excellencies,...
...distinguished delegates, ladies and gentlemen.
It is my great pleasure to address this timely meeting...
...of the United Nations Summit on Climate Change.
I was appointed as Prime Minister of Japan six days ago...
...in a historic change of government achieved through the will of the people at the recent elections.
Mr. Secretary-General,...
...climate change affects the entire globe...
...and requires long-term and international efforts.
Thus, it is imperative for all countries to address the issue...
...under the principle of common but differentiated responsibilities.
With the change of government,...
...as Prime Minister of Japan,...
...I will now seek to unite our efforts...
...to address current and future global climate change,...
...with due consideration of the warnings of science.